you very sensitive when it comes to
Michelle and when we got out there
you're sensitive when it comes to me to
my Pace no Michelle you just cried just
now but I'm not crying I'm crying for me
because I'm tired of that conversation
well this is the last time we ever
having it so don't worry after this this
is it
I don't never had care to have the
conversation it's only when you come
back to tell me something that you did
and I gotta accept them because I don't
think about her I never even met her
she's like this you words that were a
fantasy okay I feel about I feel sorry
for her because she doesn't even know
you oh God
Carlos
is this the end
are you asking me yeah I'm asking you is
this thing what about you
is this the end because she not coming
to Norway end
so if she not coming to the wedding
that's just it if you can't accept that
and that's to move forward then it must
be the end
I don't think I want to be part of
somebody who doesn't care about others
persons feelings and I'm talking about
me
because this is hurting me
foreign
that's it there's really nothing else to
talk about
[Music]
I feel devastated Valentine was my best
friend
but I also feel that he betrayed that
trust that friendship that we had
it's not what I expect from him because
I'm being honest and open to him as I've
been always
foreign
[Music]
honestly